[Musique]
bonsoir anthony bon ordre l'un fox du
jour nous amène en allemagne et lee
comme d'habitude immigration et violence
effectivement 26 secondes filmée avec un
téléphone portable 26 secondes que l'on
va découvrir ensemble regarder des
images assez floue mission lesquelles on
distingue tout même des personnes qui
s'enfuit des gens qui courent on entend
aussi des coups de feu cette vidéo elle
a été publiée le 7 mai via ce compte
twitter et vu ici plus de 1600 x on la
retrouve aussi sur youtube ou encore sur
facebook chaque fois cette légende une
fusillade entre deux groupes de migrants
à hambourg dans nord de l'allemagne
-dont entre 80 et 100 personnes
impliquées plusieurs morts à déplorer
d'où viennent ces images et quelle est
l'origine de la vidéo alors je vous
parle souvent ici de la recherche
d'image inversée là elle n'a pas été
possible tout simplement parce qu'elle
n'aurait à rien donné tant la qualité de
la vidéo de le disait n'est pas bonne
les images sont floues mais ce qui est
intéressant dans l'exemple de ce soir
c'est qu'il faut repérer plusieurs
détails visuels de la vidéo pour
retrouver facilement l'origine de la
vidéo est donc ce contexte précis là je
salue notamment le travail de nos
confrères belges de l'hebdomadaire knack
et son auteur brecht castle à l'origine
de cette enquête la première étape on va
reprendre la vidéo initial et on va
s'arrêter sur la plaque
d'immatriculation de la voiture en va
noter qu'ici il y à un des os des eaux
pour dortmund on est à plus de 300 km de
hambourg en bourse est ici dortmund
c'est ici vous allez me dire on peut
évidemment avoir une voiture
immatriculée à dortmund et être à
hambourg c'est vrai mais ça peut aussi
mettre la puce à l'oreille et c'est le
cas en l'occurrence lorsque c'est la
deuxième étape vous cherchez dortmund
mixer dans la ruhr donc si vous cherchez
sur google
les mots shooting side and shooting pour
fusillade et le mot au chur en les
limitant la première semaine de mai
puisque c'est la période où à circuler
la vidéo voici ce que vous obtenez
plusieurs articles qui évoque une
fusillade à duisbourg vous avez par
exemple ce site hongrois on le retrouve
la vidéo du tweet alors duisbourg ce
n'est pas dortmund elle aime dire c'est
vrai mais c'est également dans la ruhr
mais c'est à deux pas de dortmund
duisbourg c'est ici dortmund c'est ici
et que nous dit la presse à ce sujet
alors plusieurs médias allemands
évidemment nous apprennent qu'il y a eu
une fusillade le 4 mai dernier dans la
soirée ou à duisbourg donc dans plus
précisément dans le quartier de holborn
et près du vieux marché a littéralement
de quoi s'agit-il d'une altercation
apprend t-on dans d'autres articles
entre un groupe de motards les hells
angels et un gang criminel arabo turques
ou turco arabe entre 80 et 100 personnes
impliquées peut-on lire ici c'est ce
qu'on voyait d'ailleurs dans la
publication originale et quatre blessés
voilà pour les faits les images
satellites ensuite elles viennent
corroborer celle de la vidéo est
confirmée donc le lieu de la fusillade
la marque on retrouve ici l'arbre en
vous voyez qui a la même forme qui est
exactement au même placement on peut
noter aussi la différence de couleur à
des pavés et puis sur le côté ici ce
bâtiment en ans qui quand on regarde de
plus près est en fait un centre médical
et une pharmacie attenante que l'on
retrouve ici aussi dans la vidéo alors
dans son communiqué de presse la police
elle n'a jamais parlé de décès mais
uniquement de quatre blessés donc en
aucun cas vous l'aurez compris il ne
s'agit d'une fusillade mortelle entre
deux groupes de migrants en bourlier
vous l'avez rappelé au début de la
chronique un systématiquement la
violence à l'immigration est stigmatisée
de fait les migrants et les réfugiés
c'est évidemment un grand classique de
la désinformation mêlant fox de ce soir
montre un exemple assez simple de
déformation des faits mais aussi à un
procédé assez simple de vérification
effectivement alors ça veut pas dire que
ça prend pas du temps évidemment mais
c'est moins complexe que parfois ce que
je peux vous montrer ici et c'est pour
cette raison d'ailleurs que comme
l'équipe des observateurs de france 24
l'auteur de cette enquête bref castle
faire régulièrement sur son compte des
souhaits d'un ses fils de discussion
assez pédagogique très détaillée pour
par étapes dont pour expliquer sa
démarche est donnée aussi les clés pour
que chacun puisse finalement faire ce
travail assez simple face à l'épidémie
de fake nous a favorisés par les réseaux
sociaux et il y met un point d'honneur c
kim a expliqué tout à l'heure lorsque je
me suis entretenu avec lui écouter c'est
très important parce que j'ai seulement
24 heures dans un jour je suis texte
coeur chez fnac et je travaille beaucoup
mais il ya tellement de vidéo tellement
d'image que j'espère que c'est mon rêve
que tout le monde peut le faire c'est
vraiment un jeu bac à meaux je sais pas
si tu connais ça mais il ya des trucs
qui qui montrent du doigt le battre avec
un marteau c'est impossible de vérifier
tout c'est impossible de combattre tous
mais si tout le monde être un petit peu
et si tout le monde un peu plus critique
pense que
si tout le monde fait un peu un effort
je pense qu'on peut y arriver
merci beaucoup anthony pour ce travail
qui vous a donc pris du temps merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette demi heure
d'information se retrouve dans quelques
instants pour un nouveau journal